NBC News actively covered up Harvey
Weinstein's abuse of women that was
clear months ago when the story first
broke and we told you about it then it's
even clearer now the remarkable thing is
that NBC is still lying about it but
more elaborately in a long memo released
last night NBC News chairman Andy lack
spent 11 pages claiming that his network
couldn't air ronan pharaoh's
investigation of weinstein the same
piece that later ran in The New Yorker
and won a Pulitzer Prize there's wasn't
enough evidence lack said there weren't
any on the record allegations against
Harvey Weinstein well that is false and
now we can prove it is on her NBC show
this morning megyn kelly bravely pointed
out because she still works there that
there was in fact and on the record
source against Harvey Weinstein it was
Rose McGowan and NBC knew this because
McGowan's claim was included in a script
that made it to the very top of the
company and that included the general
counsel of the company we spoke to a
source by phone who read us the
pertinent line from that script here it
is quote in later conversations with NBC
News she rose mcgowan specifically named
Weinstein well there you have it that's
the story right there done cold
of course NBC also had videotape shot by
police in New York of Harvey Weinstein
himself confessing to abuse on camera so
they had the whole thing nailed and they
suppress it in a protected Weinstein now
they're lying about it we probably
shouldn't be surprised by any of these
this NBC News also lied about the
infamous Access Hollywood tape which
they leaked to The Washington Post on
the eve of a presidential debate in
order to influence the outcome of that
debate and the election and then to
compound the crime they fired and
humiliated their own anchor Billy Bush
for the crime of like you were not sure
what the crime was but we do know that
NBC lied to its viewers and to the rest
of us throughout that whole episode
we've asked NBC repeatedly to account
for it how did they secretly recorded
video tape that was their property get
from their offices to the hands of NBC
News chief Noah Oppenheimer's college
buddy David Farenthold at the Washington
Post we asked that question because
transparency
is at the heart of every legitimate news
organization but not at the heart of NBC
they won't answer our question that's
not surprising what is surprising if you
think about it for a minute is why NBC
didn't run the Weinstein story in the
first place they knew was factually true
it was news it was a story it met the
definition but they also more critically
knew that Ronan Farrow might hurt them
if they killed the story and of course
in the end he did hurt them badly they
knew that might happen but they killed
it anyway why did they do that we
decided to investigate this question and
we did we spoke to a number of people
with direct knowledge of this story and
here's what we got Harvey Weinstein had
a long and documented history of using
private investigators to an earth
damaging information about people who
threatened him he did that repeatedly to
many people he did it to the New York
Times for example did he do that to the
leadership of NBC people close to the
story believed that he did some within
the company believe that Weinstein
threatened to reveal damaging
information about NBC's then biggest
star Matt Lauer
so we asked NBC about this today we
asked directly they answered a number of
our questions but notably they ignored
our question about Matt Lauer completely
that's interesting here's another
question how many people within the
hierarchy of NBC knew about all of this
one obvious person to ask is Chuck Todd
he's the network's political director
he's the host of Meet the Press Todd is
a famously connected guy information is
his currency how could he not know what
was happening inside his own company NBC
gets the biggest scoop of the year and
then kills it mysteriously of course
Chuck Todd knew what does he think of
that is squelching first-person accounts
of sexual assault by powerful men
consistent with Chuck Todd's view of
journalism is it ethical did Chuck Todd
ever complain about this inside the
building at NBC why didn't he quit over
it or is it better is to shut up and
pretend that sexual assault didn't
happen in the hopes of keeping the
highest paying job he'll ever have maybe
that's the answer we don't know for sure
because Chuck Todd didn't respond to our
questions when we reached out today
but we'll call again soon we'll have
occasion to call because The Daily Beast
is preparing what sounds like a
blockbuster investigation into serious
and widespread personal misconduct both
at MSNBC and at NBC News it sounds
shocking and for a we can tell it sounds
true we'll check back with Chuck Todd
when it comes out and we'll see what he
has to say
meantime Larry O'Connor's associate
editor of The Washington Times and he
joins us tonight
so Larry NBC has changed its story just
within the last 24 hours initially and
ELAC said we had no on the record
evidence or claim of any alleged victim
of Harvey Weinstein that's all we didn't
honest right couldn't run it because
they wouldn't go on the record exactly
now the script has come to light from
last summer in which Rose McGowan is
quoted saying on the record he abused me
now lack is saying we had no on camera
on the on the record accusation a
shouldn't he admit he lied in being you
don't need it on camera account to run
it of course
I especially when you've got Harvey
Weinstein on video from the New York
Police Department basically apologizing
for the sexual assault against the one
victim that sort of blew the story apart
also can we pause for a moment and talk
about the irony of NBC News saying they
won't run a story if someone won't go on
the record
how many anonymous worst stories have
they run over the last year two years
about the Trump administration that none
of those anonymous sources go on the
record so why is it different here and
and why would it have to be a good point
and a sexual assault victim think about
that for a minute you know that takes a
lot of courage for these women to step
forward and speak with Ronan Farrow and
Rona should get tons of credit he
already has and it's all deserved to
think about the courage that these
victims had to show to come forth to
tell their stories and point the finger
to the most powerful man in Hollywood
and NBC News is aiding and abetting that
man by saying you've got to show us your
face you've got to give us your name
that that's outrageous what they did to
these women look we're all flawed and
all news organizations are flawed but
covering up for Harvey Weinstein is
really it at a different level I know a
lot of people at NBC and I like a lot of
they're some decent people there for
sure but you got to wonder how some of
these people can work there without
having addressed it Chuck Todd for
example how can
Chuck Todd host Meet the Press without
at least issuing a statement saying I
agree with Andy lacks lies where I
distance myself from his lies I mean how
can we believe what he says if he's
standing by this not
well of course Andy luck is his boss
right and by the way let's not forget
mr. Oppenheim no Oppenheim is the
president of NBC News his name is on
these memos too and he's all in on the
exact same story that we didn't have
anybody to go on the record said if he
was running around by the way running
around a lot of these executives are
running around NBC tonight I know for a
fact telling its employees just shut up
yeah and that itself I mean I don't want
to use the term cover up but is that the
behavior of a transparent integrity
fulfilled news organization I know it's
not and I hate you of the Mafia you
mention megyn kelly showing some courage
this morning coming out and saying
listen we've got three four people now
on this side of the equation Ronan
Farrow his producer Rose McGowan and one
other woman who was named in this story
saying this is what happened we were
ready we had it at Ronan Farrow has said
that the story even what made it all the
way up to the general counsel of the
network and Andy lack no Oppenheim and
all the executives are saying no megyn
kelly saying hey someone's lying here
she wants an independent investigation
how about that irony should we get a
special counsel who does that you
investigate awful lot of guts and I hope
that she gets the credit for the guts I
mean that's what journalism is when you
stand up and say the unpopular but true
thing do you think that's being rewarded
at NBC not at all what's being rewarded
as Chuck Todd you know Chuck - you
mentioned Chuck Todd he spent the last
several days talking a lot about
journalism talking a lot about how the
media is the most unpopular entity in
this country right now and he's blaming
everybody except you know clean up your
own house look at what's going on in
your buildings so in other words your
company covers up for an accused sex
criminal and you never address it but
you're empowered to lecture everyone
else about their shortcoming that
appears to be what mr. Todd has been BC
to say Chuck Todd look we're not
accusing you of hurting anybody or being
Harvey Weinstein we're accusing you of
abetting a cover-up working for a
company that obviously participated in a
cover-up for Harvey what do you address
it yeah yeah you would think that they
should be asking those tough questions
if mr. Todd but I haven't seen it quite
yet what we're asking them now we are
duck a lot of cowards and journalism
every year not among them thank you for
joining us tonight I appreciate you